♪♪
[ "Stranger Things"
theme plays ]
-Hey, guys. We're the cast
of "Stranger Things."
And we're here at
Madame Tussauds wax museum
in Times Square.
And we're gonna surprise some
fans who think they're here
to see a new
"Stranger Things" wax exhibit.
-Yeah, we're just
waiting on Jimmy.
-Coming! Coming!
Hi. I'm here.
I'm Barb from Season 1.
-Yeah, we get it.
-We know.
-We realize.
-Let's surprise people!
[ All cheering ]
-Everyone get in the zone.
Get in the Zen.
-No laughing.
-Yep.
-All right, shh.
♪♪
-This is our photographer.
You can sit on the bench and
then you can look at -- Yeah.
Come sit.
-Oh, great.
-All right,
now you can take a photo
if you look
right in this lens here.
Okay. And 3, 2, 1...
-[ Screams ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-How you doing?
-Oh!
-Jimmy Fallon. I'm Barb. Hi.
[ Laughs ]
-Great.
-Okay, great. Okay?
3, 2, 1...
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Can I just sit down?
-Oh [bleep]
-Oh, my God!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Big smiles. And 3, 2, 1...
-Can I get a tissue?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Look at this shirt.
That is what I'm talking about.
"Justice for Barb."
-All right.
-3, 2, 1...
-Hey, guys.
-Whoa!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Are you guys --
-We like four.
-Come see Barb.
-Barb. Look, look.
-Hey, Barb.
-Oh, hi. I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Nice to...
[ Laughter ]
Hello. I'm Barb.
-Oh!
-We look so stupid.
[ Laughter ]
You scared the crap out of me.
"Oh, man! Don't do that."
-[ Laughs ]
Can we get him
a change of pants?
-Okay, take a look back like
you're scared of the Demogorgon.
Like, look back at that.
-Aaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Oh, my God!
-Okay. In 3, 2, 1...
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
And 3, 2, 1...
[ All scream ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Oh, my God!
-Hi. How you doing?
-Oh! Don't cry.
Everybody in. Squeeze!
-1, 2, 3...
-Hey!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey guys.
I'm here with Michelle Obama.
And we're about to
surprise some people.
They're going
on a tour of 30 Rock.
They think they're going on
a tour of 30 Rock.
And they're going to stop
on the wrong floor --
this floor.
And that's where we step in.
Ready to do this?
-Yeah.
Cat. Mama.
-And we're leading.
-This is great, Jimmy.
-Oh, my God.
-This is a great book.
This is a great book.
You got to read this book.
Is your book good?
-I think this is
really intelligent.
-And I can...
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Screams ]
-Ever seen a magic trick?
Check this out. Watch this.
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Hi, guys.
-Hey!
-♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride in
a one-horse open sleigh ♪
Happy holidays.
-Hi.
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you okay?
-Hey, guys.
You mind if I go down?
I just want to --
Actually, you know what?
We'll take the next one.
-Wait, wait, wait.
I thought we were --
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Hey. How you doing?
Happy holidays.
Wait.
I'm like, "Forgive me."
-Uh...oh, well.
-Perfect.
-Okay.
Well, why don't we
just take the stairs?
-No, I thought that you were --
We were both gonna --
-Why are you such a wimp?
-I can walk back up if you want.
-Whatever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-All right. Here we go.
Big smiles.
And 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
3, 2, 1.
And 3, 2, 1.
[ Laughter ]
3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Aah! [ Screams ]
-We should do a triple piggyback
in one of these.
-And 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, this next one,
we're getting lei'd.
-All right, big smile.
And 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
One more. 3, 2, 1.
[ Laughter ]
-Never been done before --
the triple hoagie.
-All right, and big smile.
And 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Is it crazy to just have
that come out of my fly?
-Here.
-I can just --
-Best thing
I've ever heard in my life.
-And big smiles,
and 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
I'm going to get another one
like that, and 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
3, 2, 1.
Let's get one more,
and 3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-What's up, bro?
-Oh, my God!
It's Jimmy Fallon!
-What's up, my man?
-Holy cow! Captain America.
-Captain America, yeah.
-You want to do it jump
over my shoulders?
-I can. If you just drop your
head, I can get up.
-3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
3, 2, 1.
-Oh, my God!
-What's with the Seahawk fans?
-Let's get a group shot.
-Everybody say "Super Bowl."
-Super Bowl!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]